[Musique]
est ce que cette vocation de la pêche
que tu sembles avoir elle vient du fait
aussi que que ton père et marin donc pas
vraiment ce que enfin moi j'aime bien la
meilleure conçu pour ça que j'ai voulu
aussi à l'écart et j'ai aussi des parce
qu'ils étaient bretons quand même on
nous ne sommes pas spécialement n'a pas
eu d'autre d'autres ambitions t'as pas
eu envie un certain mouvement d'être
autre chose que même si j'ai voulu un
certain temps être électricien en
bâtiment
mais alors j'étais passé bleu à l'école
tu as fait que je retourne là les
week-ends espace comment qu'est ce que
tu fais mais je vais au cinéma et au
balcon tu vas quoi au bal quoi que tu
fais ovale
là je danse drague un peu mais je drague
aussi enfin pourquoi trouvez quoi je
sais quoi et oui tu reçu oui je me
levais je n'ai que cinq heures du matin
gilbert embarque température 4° trois
heures plus tard le bateau et sur le
lieu de pêche choisi par le patron je
salue à l'eau la journée chemin
je
tout ce que gilbert apprend à l'école
lui servira sur le bateau les petits
chalutiers n'ont pas de spécialistes
promotion de soudage de matelotage de
navigation sont indispensables le
perfectionnement se fera plus tard sur
le temps 10h30
après 2h30 de pêche le patron décide de
remonter le chalut l'angoissent
s'installe bonne pêche filets vides
avarie on y pense nous ont enfermés
on travaille dans cette zone
c'est surtout la langoustine qu'on
espère dès le 1er chalutage si on en
revanche sept ou huit caisses la journée
commence vial sinon quelquefois on pêche
un énorme rocher celle avarie le chalut
percer il faut leur demander
c'est du temps perdu du travail gratuit
la fif au sort l'école était là pour
enseigner la technique on prenait son
temps on s'appliquait sur le bateau il
faut aller vite
la prêche en dépend
toute la journée se passe ainsi
on jette le chalut à la mer on drague le
font deux ou trois heures et de
langoustines souhaité rendre avec elle
la roussette la lotte quelques sols et
quantité d'autres poissons un noble
quelquefois donc c'est un caillou et des
accrocs dans le filet on répare qui on
rejette le chalut pour une seconde près
pendant ce temps on trie la première
pêche en classe le poisson on le prépare
pour la vente puis le second chalut
remonte et on recommence alors touristes
toujours fana pour une sortie en mer
vous allez faire en mer c'est-à-dire
embarqué est ce que vous êtes à l'aise
sur l'eau destination le mal de mer
là parmi vous qui a le mal de mer toi et
ça te fait pas peur 17h quelques
chalutiers moins gourmands ou plus
chanceux que les autres sont à quai
c'est maintenant l'heure des comptes
le pêcheur mais pas mettre des prix sa
pêche vais t'acheter 3000 francs
chaque marin aura 300 francs gilbert 150
c'est un débutant le reste ira au bateau
c'est à dire au patron qui en est le
propriétaire
c'est qu'un bateau ça coûte cher huit
cent mille à un million de nos francs
avec les équipements indispensables 100
millions anciens plus les intérêts à
rembourser en disant on comprend que la
flottille ne se renouvelle pas gilbert
et moi pourtant devenir patron un jour
18h les derniers chalutier rentrer au
port avec leurs hommes fatigués et gares
demain à 5h on embarque
enfin moi je viens de villers guislain
j'aime bien la mère géniale peau j'aime
bien
j'aime bien rentrer chez moi comme ça
parce que les combats bonjour je me
plais ici tu crois que sans pareil quand
tu travailleras non parce que là ça va
changer que j'aimerais vraiment aller
jusqu'à vraiment fatigué bonsoir que
j'allais juli et l'a ensuite voir que je
me relève c'est pas mon avis ne purent
c'est très dur
[Musique]